they sent us on an assault that night he
said everybody in my unit was decimated
he said I was literally in the on the
ground in a foxhole I he said I was
balling he said I was crying baby
because I knew that I was going to die
he's like and then I remembered that I
had this device that you gave me he
turned it on and he just curled up in a
ball and all he did was just listen to
God's word as bombs and bullets are
exploding all around
him hey everybody Welcome to a special
edition of Ed live with the Meyer
Brothers we got Brock Meyer back in the
show Welcome Brock and uh I think you
guys are going to have a great uh a
great time with today's show because it
really hits at the heart of um some very
exciting things I think we're witnessing
the end of the world here as stuff is
getting worse and worse and worse um
what people are in need of is Hope and
uh I think you're going to hear that out
of this conversation today Brock's got
an awesome Ministry um he actually has
been ring around and going to some of
these very dangerous places in the earth
and spreading the gospel on the front
line so I'm going to let him tell you a
little bit about that but uh you're
going to want to hear the impact that
this guy is having it is absolutely
beautiful and I hope and pray that you
are blessed by Today's Show so Brock
tell us a little bit about uh Gideon
rescue and what you've been up to you've
been in in in some pretty EXC ing parts
of the earth and where is that yeah um
it's been an amazing journey for the
past 13 years God has really taught us
some incredible lessons in the disaster
Zone that's been our training ground um
and one thing we were taught early on
was you know what is the most important
uh thing that somebody needs in a crisis
moment and so it it all comes down
exactly what you said it's hope you know
when humanity is unique in the sense
that you know we are the only species on
this Earth that thrives off of Hope and
we see that in society all around us the
world has falling apart at an
unprecedented rate as we speak and what
determines whether you thrive or whether
you don't survive is your ability to
hang on to hope and so in these disaster
zones that's that's really what we're
going after first and foremost is giving
people hope and so you know one might
ask well okay so what kind of hope are
you going after and and this is what I
think think is so amazing you know when
you talk about Little Light Studios and
the work that you guys are doing you
know when you're in a crisis moment or
in a disaster Zone you know there there
really is no power in hoping in Disney
you know there is no power in hoping in
Marvel like there is no power in hoping
in in in any of the entertainment that's
out there all of a sudden the the leev
the playing field is leveled like never
before because you recognize that these
things that that we have been sold on
cheap entertainment is what it is very
cheap entertainment um it it doesn't
fulfill the the Soul's greatest need in
crisis because you're not going to look
up and see Superman you know you're not
going to look up and see you know your
favorite character coming to rescue you
um the only person that can actually
help you in these crisis moments is God
and he's given us uh a hope that is
worth hanging on to worth worth giving
everything for and so our firm belief
when we come to these disaster zones is
is people need the Lord just like that
song that old school song you know
people need the Lord like never before
right and and this this is what people
need and so um as we've made that our
Pursuit and our passion like God has
pulled out the stops and he has opened
every door for us to be able to gain
critical access to hearts and Minds when
they're hurting the most amen well you
know as as I've worked in Ministry now
for um pretty close to almost 15 years I
I I go to work and I sit at a niceu
computer in a controlled uh uh
temperatured room and uh you know I'm
sharing the gospel best that I can via
the Internet H but I'll tell you what
you're out there obviously wearing a
bulletproof vest right now so uh show us
a little bit of this bulletproof vest
because I think this thing is really
neat like you don't really think of
ministry as like being literally on the
front lines and Rockets going over your
head stuff exploding and you're sharing
the gospel and I love what you said
about like in that situation nobody's
sitting there thinking about man I'm so
glad I saw the latest movie or you know
I just I just want to go home and play
video games I mean your whole world of
what becomes important bubbles to the
surface and uh I think it's rad that you
have a team Brock that literally will
strap on some bulletproof vests and go
out into the fire and share the gospel
well I you know I can say um yeah this
is a BPR vest uh I feel funny wearing it
CU I'm not I'm not a soldier I'm not
trained as a soldier but there's some
key features about this vest that um
have we have we have found to give us
greater access to hearts and Minds
actually I will disagree with you I
think you are a
soldier just not in the sense that
you're carrying around a weapon taking
life you're actually saving life yeah
yeah no that's very true like we're not
about taking life we're about preserving
life because all life is viable you know
to God you know we know these verses for
God does not desire that any perish but
all come to everlasting life amen so
when you recognize that then there are
no political lines there are no party
lines there is no left versus the right
life becomes so sacred and so valuable
that you're willing to yeah run into the
fire to so that others might live you
know is the Mantra and so I mean this
vest it it's just man's you know take on
on how to keep somebody safe in in just
a absolutely nightmarish situation um
and so you know yes it's a plate carrier
it has you know we carry a um a steel
plate or ceramic plate in here and
there's some extra medical supplies here
these are um tourniquets you know got
some darts for some Airways um and then
Pockets Galore and velcro which actually
really helps um in a couple of ways
number one we can actually carry one of
my favorite things on this vest is
actually this little uh pouch here it's
actually made for um discarding
magazines so when you're out there and
you're like Po and you're ditching
magazines those magazines are expensive
so they make these little bags so you
can stuff your magazines in there but
obviously we're not out there with
AR-15s or M16s and so it's perfect
because we can fit our God pods or our
books or our cards or whatever it is
that we're fitting in there so then when
you're in the field you can actually
pull it out give him a picture that's a
picture of Jesus coming again um or
you're handing them you know God's word
in audio form now in this little audio
player and the soldiers absolutely love
it I absolutely love this idea because
here you're using an ammo bag for ammo
but it's just not the ammo that you
actually think right you're blasting
arrows of truth if you would and how are
people responding to that I mean when
you go you've been to the Ukraine you've
been to Israel like like you've seen
some of these places where there is some
pretty intense fighting like are people
like get away from me I got you know
things I got to do or how are they
responding to you handing them a piece
of literature oh man it's it's it's you
know it's heartbreaking because I think
you get a glimpse into you know what
Jesus what Jesus saw as he looked out
and he saw the vast multitudes and he
saw them as like sheep without a
shepherd and and this is really what the
context of what you see when you walk
into these environments is that these
are people that are so precious but
they're so lost like they don't
understand the greater picture of what's
Happening you know just like the Bible
says we wrestle not against flesh and
blood but against principalities and
powers and wickedness and darkness in
high places like if people could only
understand that the external for what we
see is not the reality of what's
actually happening there's a battle
between good and evil the only currency
in this world that matters is souls and
that's what's being traded won or lost
on a daily basis and so um how do you
reach people I mean that becomes a
driving force in everything I mean
that's what you guys are doing with
little light I mean even though you may
not be on the front lines you are on the
front lines because you are you are
pumping out the truth beaming it into
somebody's cell phone and they're
watching it and and it's changing or
shifting their perspective in hopefully
in favor of Eternity um and I I think in
these crisis moments it's that same
principle but it's just multiplied times
50 you know or 100 because now um you
know in some of these places that we've
been um especially in in in Ukraine or
in Israel um you know I remember in
Israel they were taking away all the
soldiers cell phones you know so here
they are grabbing their cell phones
saying check them in they put them in a
lock box and the soldiers now have
nothing when it comes to Media nothing
so you can't watch YouTube you can't you
can't you know listen to your favorite
rap music you know you can't you know
spend all your hours on Facebook or
looking at inappropriate videos or
images of whatever um but in that moment
is an amazing moment where you can hand
somebody then the right kind of media
right so you give them the right kind of
media and now that Soldier going in for
let's say a a six day journey into Gaza
and he's now stuck in that Gaza Strip in
some heavy fighting he's going to see
horrible things he may lose some of his
guys next to him and and now you've just
armed him with God's word and and as he
goes through those experiences he now
actually has an opportunity to choose
life okay so so the whole Bible is
loaded up onto this thing called a god
pod yeah yeah the whole the whole thing
these are little audio yeah yeah you can
put it in any language this one's in
Hebrew and in English cuz this one came
from Israel um and so we literally just
loaded it up with the full Bible the New
Testament on there as well um and and
that was a big question you know when we
were loading them people said well you
know they're Jews they don't want to
listen to the New Testament and you know
what the world is failing people I mean
we know this Revelation 14 Babylon is
Fallen is Fallen right so it doesn't
matter what culture what country what
religion you come from you recognize the
systems of man are not giving you what
your Soul really needs and people know
this like this is not this is not uh
foreign you know any place you go and in
Israel there's no exception they they
feel like their government has failed
them they're now in this crazy bid for
trying to you know uh keep their Nation
alive in the midst of all this hatred
that's coming at them from every
direction and so they're they they see
the great controversy they know that
that that something's not right and so
when you connect them with Biblical
truth and you say hey guys like we're
here on a mission we're here on a
mission to give you hope we're here on a
mission to give you message um they are
excited about it they want to read about
it they want to hear about it and so
really we have very little resistance
when it comes to um you know people
turning us away and saying No thank you
you know I remember I was even in
Ukraine and and you know I gave it to a
a full-on Satanist like fullon he was
like I worship Satan I don't want your
Bible and I just had my translator
preach to him like Hey man like of all
people you need this more than anyone
else and as my translator told them that
like it just it broke down those
barriers he recognized that wow none of
my Satanist friends are coming here to
help me but here's this crazy Christian
that's here to give me message of Hope
like well maybe I should actually listen
to it and he took it and he was so
grateful so um I think when we're in a
crisis moment that's when we're most
willing to listen I mean that's what
they say there's no atheist and foxholes
and that's that's that's incredible like
if you were to say what's the
receptivity rate you know in a conflict
or a crisis a disaster Zone the
receptivity rate is nearly 100% you get
a few sticks in the mud that are like no
thank you I'm going to deny God to the
to the to the very last breath but most
people when they're in deep trouble
they'll fall on their knees they'll say
God where are you right and that's
literally the moment that God needs like
like like I hope you guys are hearing
this right now because this is so
hitting at the heart of the Gospel this
is how patient and loving God Is Right
all he's got to do is plant that seed in
there and all you've got to do is give
him that heart like Lord I've messed up
or I didn't believe in you or whatever
like this if you're literally at that
moment of on your deathbed and you go
God I want you he's merciful I mean the
thief on the cross proves that right and
so I remember you telling me a story
that you pulled up to a a little guard
shack way in the middle of like nowhere
uh kind of on the road to going to Gaza
right and you were starting to hand
these things out uh what was the
reception like at at this just in the
middle of nowhere
you know I I think it becomes laughable
almost at some point because I mean we
carry US passports you know and and a
lot of these missions they happen so
quickly we don't have the proper time to
contact all the authorities and get all
the ducks in the road Vis get escorted
and you know all those details and so
we're really moving by faith we're like
Lord if you want us see you're going to
have to open the door because because
because listen it's not about us like
we're we're literally just Flesh and
Bones underneath these these little
tactical vests you know and and and and
often times uh we have to we have to
just go where God opens up those doors
and so we did end up in a situation
where um you know every time we'd come
up to a checkpoint they'd say what are
you doing here and and we would hand
them pull out the audio Bible that we
had we say God sent us here for this and
we'd give it to them and they would take
it and they'd be so excited like oh man
this is so amazing thank you so much and
and they're like we can't believe you're
here doing this like and and I think
it's because it really catches them off
guard like like you know when you're in
a who are you and why are you
when you're in a desperate bid for for
life and death where you have bombs and
Rockets and missiles and you know
bullets flying everywhere you know when
somebody shows up and says hey you know
like now is the time to consider your
eternal security you know your soul yeah
then then people they really take stock
in that because they're already thinking
about it you know and so really every
checkpoint this was our passport like we
stopped showing our passports in Ukraine
in Israel we sto they they stopped
asking for our passports if we were
faith when we rolled down the window and
showed them this immediately as as they
asked us who we were and what we were
doing no
problem mindblowing where Christianity
is the Infidel you are the enemy of the
the the Eastern idea right the Western
world is like you know gone off The
Rocker to these people and here they're
being receptive to it I think that's
absolutely beautiful but yeah what a
what a what a crazy situation a bunch of
Christians like literally roaming around
when Tactical gear handing out versions
of the Bible in their language and I
mean that is probably such a stark like
whoa I wasn't expecting that today and
then all of a sudden I wish we could be
flies on the wall because I'm sure if
you could just hear the conversation
between those people when they left dude
was that an angel like you know they
might start thinking you know did God
directly send these people down and and
in a weird way yes it was but but they
don't know you from Adam they you know
and and to see actually accept it and I
think you even told me um you had a
couple experiences where people were
like well well well can I have like
three or four of them some of my buddies
over here and then can you go over to
that guard shack down the road a little
bit I'm sure they'd want some too and
they're like directing you to their
friends yeah yeah yeah and that's the
awesome thing about it is
that people recognize the truth like
that's that's I it says in the
scriptures that God has planted eternity
in everybody's heart and so that is
something that is inherent to our our
very being at our core doesn't matter
who you are doesn't matter what what
religious persuasion you are every
single one of us knows that there is
eternity and if that means there's
eternity that means it's eternity to be
won or or lost and so when when you show
up in these situations people are
excited and they want their friends to
know and that's the beauty of what the
gospel is it's the good news when you
say angel angel simply just means
Messenger right so God desires his
people to be me Messengers for him to
give the good news and that's why the
commission the gospel commission is to
every tribe every tongue every Kindred
across the entire Globe there's not a
single people group that won't be
represented on that sea of glass when we
get to heaven you know so so why not be
in it to win it and that's the question
we had to ask ourselves you know um and
this was this is a tough question you
know all most of us within Gideon rescue
company are actually family men I have
three kids myself and a wife and uh we
had to to really struggle with this as a
family and and work through this
together because we had to ask the
question okay Lord like you know who who
is actually the best qualified to send
into some of these dangerous areas you
know who who would be the best one to
put forward and and it really has to be
a Christian who understands where
they're going right who who understands
the risk and is willing to take on that
risk so that some body else can live
because if you and I are we're secure in
our faith and our belief like hey we
know where we're headed you know our our
names are written in the Book of Life we
believe that by faith then there's a
whole world out there that doesn't have
that hope that doesn't have that belief
so then so then it becomes the
Christian's duty to actually be in some
of the most difficult places around the
world so that people can receive hope
like who else who's else going to go
like the scripture again says you know
unless they hear by preaching how are
they going to know and unless somebody
goes as a a preacher then how are they
going to ever have the opportunity and
you know paraphrase and and that's
exactly the situation that we have is
that you know there there's a there's a
huge component of this that really just
is obedience and responding I mean it's
so inspiring to me because when I read
the stories in the Bible and I think
about like some of those early Apostles
and the disciples and when they were
willing to go around I mean some of them
are family men right we know Peter had a
wife and uh you know they're willing to
put themselves in some very dangerous
situations getting stoned and dying just
to hopefully let me just win one more
let me just let me just get one more
over here and you know uh I think uh
part of our downfall is we're in such a
comfortable environment where we're at
we like our little house you know we go
to church and you know we get this like
kind of comfortable existence going on
when the rest of the world is in
absolute shambles and turmoil and it's
like you know they're over there just
blowing each other up hatred just
fueling on either side of the fence
right and and you guys don't even care
about that you're not there to see which
side is the right side even if it was
the enemy and you thought that was the
enemy that soul is still worthy of you
putting a Bible in their hand and going
man just make a choice for God I mean
that to me is literally the heart of the
Gospel I personally have not put myself
in a position that I I I think I might
not come home from this you know like
there's an OP there's a chance that I
will not survive this or that I'm going
into this you know uh with all right God
you know it's all all all of it's in
yours but that to me is inspiring that
you guys are willing to do that you're
you're you're a bunch of paramedics and
nurses and I mean a different varieties
and walks of life I think you've you've
you've brought you know real estate
agents and just random people on some of
these trips right um but I think it's
beautiful the chance that I've had to
talk with some of the people that have
been over there with you and heard the
stories from you you're over there
changing their lives but really
ultimately it's also changing your life
in a big way coming back your faith is
going you know exponentially
huge you know and and honestly really
like we're we're really nobody's special
like this is not like you know
a big
operation yeah we're not ex Navy Seals
we don't have an unlimited budget like
all we have is is you know the faith
that that and I think our faith has
really grown you know this is not
something happened overnight you know 13
years we've been doing Disaster Response
and God has been bringing us we've in
fact we never even considered conflict
zones that was something that was really
off the table for us in a big way
because you know we were like look like
we have no interest we have no interest
in war we have no interest in being
there but I think as as our eyes were
open with the with the Ukraine conflict
you know over a year ago when this
started um we just recognize that the
same principles are at play and even
magnified because if you ask the
question who stands at the risk of a
christless eternity more than anybody
else it would have to be the civilian or
Soldier is exposed to death and
destruction on a daily basis some of
these people you know like in Israel
they live with the threat of death every
single day Death from Above death from a
bus stop like when we were there in
Jerusalem one of the very places we
visited just to go you know see a couple
sites in the city like the day uh after
we were there there was like some
terrorist that just walked off and and
just Gunn down everybody at the bus stop
and this is this is the reality of where
people like this world is not getting
any better it's becoming much more
violent you know everywhere we turn and
you're not guaranteed tomorrow and so
like if there was ever a time now for
some hope and some encouragement and to
let people know their true identity as
God sees them then then then then this
is the need and and it requires still
hands to be able to go and to minister
to people in in in that way um and so
it's it's uh I think the the power
really that we've learned as we've gone
through this is just trusting the
promises that are in God's word you know
there's some incredible promises in
God's word you know like incredible
promis like this is where the word comes
alive you know it's living it's sharper
than any two-edged sword it's better
than any weapon that this world could
muster or manufacture God's word could
could defeat anything right and so if we
believe that by faith then it it's not a
it's not a presumptuous move it's it's a
move of bold Faith to look at the
situation just like David did or just
like any other Mighty Men Who were in
the Bible who said you know what this
situation is not right there are people
at you know that are at risk here and so
therefore it requires action for me to
do something for me to step forward to
me to say Lord here I am send me
and and as you put your confidence in
God's word then the promises become true
like God says I'll I will send out my
word and it's going to accomplish the
thing that I've sent it to do it will
not return to me void and and so when
you when you see those promises in
action it's it's faith building I mean
you're like whoa this is so incredible
God walks You Through the Bible so tell
me about the experience that you had
speaking about this exact thing right
here you don't know if you are going to
even make it through the night and you
got an opportunity to um hands some God
pods to a team of I think it was Navy
Seals is type people and then um they
took them away and you heard something
tragic happened tell us a little bit
about that yeah that was in Israel um I
you know um it happens on all sides you
know where we've been um but I'll
highlight a couple one from Israel one
from Ukraine um we had a group of of
guys that were part of a special Elite
unit within Israel and um they were
right on the border with God and so all
these soldiers are going in you know
they're coming out they're going in and
they're exposed to really you know just
horrible things you know like war is so
horrible and and especially Modern
Warfare today is so cowardly you know
it's at least back in the day you had to
look your enemy in the eye you know as
you thrust him through with your sword
but I mean which I think that would be
terribly difficult yeah it would still
be it would still be horrible right but
I mean at least you you know like hey we
are going to now grapple you know person
to person and and that requires a whole
level of hon and and bravery that is
just not present in Modern Warfare today
um in many ways it's easy to press a
button and hurl an explosive at somebody
exactly you know we're so disconnected
from you know like I even launching an
RPG or a rocket like you have no idea
like where that's going what level of
destructions CA you never see that on
the other end you just are the one that
initiates it it's like playing a video
game yeah and and so here we met this
whole and that's really what it is like
when you want to talk about video games
um man it's so evil like you know all
this Modern Warfare Call of Duty these
video games that are so actively you
know at our Forefront of our
minds the reality of what's being built
on the ground around the world is that
we're now stepping into not just the the
gaming theater it's now the reality of
actually you know the practice in The
Art of War um and it's it's just it's so
cowardly I mean there's so many things
about it that are just Absolut evil but
um we met this unit going into AA and um
these guys were I think an ordinance
artillery unit and they were just
lobbing like grenades and you know
missiles and things all over the wall
into Gaza we were literally on the wall
between Israel and
Gaza and um I think we had been uh they
had an opportunity to deliver some food
so we were there like delivering them
some food but of course we saw it as
like hey this is not just an opportunity
to deliver food actually give these guys
like the gospel right so here we we got
20 minutes so what are you going to tell
somebody in 20 minutes like it's just it
it's it's hard you know like and so we
run up and we try to connect with them
and like hey and they you know they want
to know who we are and where we're from
and you know do we have families and
like so you know in this friendly
exchange of getting to know these guys
um you know they even had a tourniquet
they wanted to see how fast an American
could put on a tourniquet versus you
know Israeli and so we had this little
contest putting on these tourniquet so
it just it was great like God gave us
the perfect entrance the perfect
opportunity to gain that trust quickly
and then I remember distinctly one of
the guys he looked at me and he I was
wearing this vest and he points at this
patch and he says he says what is that
on your vest and I was just like oh this
is perfect right and I actually was
filming this actually is a a case for my
phone so my phone was in here and it was
totally rolling the entire time
beautiful and uh I just I just told him
I said hey man I said we are here on a
special forces Mission but not in the
way that you think this is not about
Flesh and Blood this is not about
Palestinians versus Israelis I said
we're here to deliver you a message of
Hope and that's what's on this audio
player that we're given to each one of
you guys like you guys got to go back
you got to listen to it please promise
me listen to what you're you know what's
on here because it's going to explain it
in depth and detail it's going to be
amazing and then I said as far as this
patch I said we've got three bars here
the three bars represent three messages
that come from Revelation 14 because
there's three angels that are giving us
three warnings at the very final close
of Earth's history and it's very simple
number one remember your identity who
has created you right fear God and give
him glory for the hour of his judgment
is come we're living in a time of
judgment you're seeing the failure the
systems around us that ties right into
the second message Babylon is Fallen you
you're going to recognize that the
government here in Israel is going to
fail you you're going to recognize that
Hamas and terrorist groups are going to
the United States and and everybody else
that is around the world is going to
fail you because Babylon is fallen and
there's no fixing it we're not going to
save this ship from going down it's
going down hardcore so therefore the
last message which is super important is
don't receive the mark of that system
like get in the Lifeboat and the only
safety that that that we have to get in
that boat is God's word right so like
break it down to him real simply and man
they were just they were like in awe
they were they were just like this is
amazing like yeah please tell we want to
know more well sadly we only have 20
minutes with them and right now the guy
in in the Jeep yelling at us he's like
come on time to go like let's go and
it's like a you know just breaks your
heart because you want to stay with
these guys for like the next six hours
Bible study and like just share the
truth with these guys right um but you
know you have what you have and and
that's what God granted Us in that
moment and uh sadly I think a couple
days later we learned that that eight
guys from that unit the very guys that
we were visiting and interacting with
eight of those guys lost their lives in
a in an assault or an attack or
something that happened and so wow so
when you see how small that window is
right the devil's desire is to destroy
people for eternity and he doesn't care
how he does it he doesn't care if it's
the wrong road through pornography and
destroying all of your relationships or
or or if it's or if it's through the the
the short road of of a drug deal gone
bad I work as a paramedic on an
ambulance and and man it kills me the
other day I worked this this guy that uh
a young guy he's my age you know 30 33
years old I'm a little older than that
but 33 years old and uh he went to just
go buy some weed in in the in the park
and the guys instead of selling him the
weed they saw he had a water of cash and
they tried to Rob him he said no I'm not
giving up my money they shot him point
blank in the chest and it was just like
wow over a $20 bag of weed for for one
small decision your life has now been
altered
forever forever so um he actually did
survive we ended up getting him on a
helicopter and and getting him down to
trauma center but I think he's paralyzed
from the W waste down as a result which
is just which is just another way that
the devil wants to just just make sure
that your soul is destroyed forever
right like unless unless you have hope
right that's that's the thing unless you
have hope in a God who can solve even
the worst of situations because the
Bible says all things work together for
good to those love God and called
according to his purpose so unless you
have that
hope that's the only thing that's going
to carry you through and so that's what
motivates us like man these soldiers
they're going to see the same kind of
stuff man like one of their buddies
going to get shot he may die he may
survive with horrible deficits and
wounds for the rest of his days you know
and you you know he's going to be
recalled to that conversation and it
maybe was just one conversation that you
had with him one seed one thing and he's
going to be sitting there laid up in the
hospital going wait I got this like godp
pod thing in my pocket like what is this
can't move let's just listen to it and
man that guy's going to be one to the
kingdom you know something as simple as
that when when we were when we were in
Ukraine when we were in Ukraine uh Dylan
tells this story he was another guy that
was with me another buddy of mine that
that's uh been involved with this
there's only been about three of us like
when I say small operation there's like
three four of us that have been involved
in this kind of stuff like we're not
we're not some huge team it's a drop in
the bucket the Harvest is great the
laborers are few and uh Dylan handed one
of these devices to a Ukrainian guy that
was real hesitant to take it he's like I
don't know man and so but eventually he
took it like three or four days later
this same guy tracked us down he found
us cuz we kind of circled around the
same area hit the same spots and so he
found us he saw us and came running up
to us said I have to tell you the day
that you gave that to me they sent us on
an assault that night he said everybody
in my unit was decimated I he said I was
literally in the on the ground in a
foxhole I he said I was Bing he said I
was crying like a baby because I knew
that I was going to die he's like and
then I remembered that I had this device
that you gave me and he said he pulled
it out he pulled it out of his jacket
out of his flak jacket he turned it on
and he just curled up in a ball and all
he did was just listen to God's word as
bombs and bullets are exploding all
around him and and he said he said I
know that I was spared that night
because of this that you gave me he said
what is this and it was like oh man this
is the greatest this is the greatest you
know message in the world and he was
like can I have more for my friends
please like how many can you give me to
to hand out to my friends he's like
there are other men in my unit that need
to have this device and it's like man
you know like there there is power in
the word like like like this is such a
crazy day and age that we live in like
like you think and you've heard of these
stories of people that had a Bible in
their chest and somebody shot them and
the Bible stopped the bullet I mean
here's an example of digital words
literally running through a computer on
a little tiny thing that saved
somebody's life I mean that's that's
God's word now I I haven't been shot yet
but I will tell you this when we went
into when we went into Israel this last
time this is actually a book called
Desire of Ages and it's in Arabic um and
it's really it's just a beautiful book
Desire of Ages by the way is about this
the life of Jesus and beautiful book
beautiful book if you haven't read that
amazing amazing and and we had a
challenge because um I we didn't have
time we we had one set of plates for my
buddy I I didn't have time um to grab we
we didn't have another set of plates and
most of the time when we go to Ukraine
we just pick them up when we're in
Ukraine because there's plates like
everywhere you can go to military
surplus stores and everything and um in
Israel we kind of thought well maybe
we'll find some other plates there too
so my vest didn't have any plates and so
um going in there actually what I ended
up doing was I ended up stuffing the
Desire of Ages up inside my plate
carrier um and and that's all I had was
just a book you know um between me and
my chest you know but but and and it's
not a it's just it's just another
illustration of like how important do we
really value you know the gospel and and
these these resources that point people
to Jesus you know is it is it what they
need is it what could give you that
physical protection um I believe so I
mean we see we see stories of this all
the time where it's like man if I just
had one more resource you know to hand
somebody um it's like that Schindler's
List movie you know it's like you get to
the end of it and and you don't want
want to be sitting there with that gold
ring on your finger and saying Lord I I
could have I could have reached one more
person with this ring you know yep I
know I think about that all the time and
I go at some point we're going to have
to like release all of the little castle
stuff that we're building up here in
this Kingdom and and if it can be used
for the gospel or used to spread the
message I mean nobody's going to get to
heaven and be like man I'm so glad I got
three houses and you know I got a BMW
sitting in my driveway no one's going to
say that you're going to talk about the
people that you should have gone and
talked to the the the the little
experiences that you had right here that
you could have changed someone's life
you could have handed something to them
that would have been revolutionary to
them and they walk away from you and per
perhaps that was their last moment and
so um you know I think I think it is
absolutely beautiful and and to hear you
know your reaction in the face of death
how you actually respond to those things
I know you have a video clip that I want
you to play um that is absolutely a
beautiful illustration of somebody that
you know um caught the vision of what
your ministry is all about and um for
those of you that don't know I I I want
to you know I want to inspire you to
look Gideon rescue up we will put the
link in the description below but but
take a time to to um see some of the
things that these guys have put out
they've they've got a YouTube channel
that they're putting some content out
with some of the stories that that have
been happening they're working on a
documentary right now which is a huge
huge like you know undertaking I mean
they they had a filmer um that just went
with them to Israel and and and tell us
a little bit about that Brock because I
think this is a really interesting thing
that God is also doing trying to get
these stories out to help inspire people
um how did you get a filmer to go with
you into this
situation yeah I mean uh well you know
I've been I've been bugging you for a
long time like man we gota we got to
film this we got to capture this and and
uh and you know how you know you guys
know it l how tedious it is is to like
film and cut and edit and put together
and and and none of us are filmers or
photographers or editors and so we're
always at the short end of the stick
literally just filming with our iPhones
what we can capture and the stories are
so compelling and so inspiring to us
that we feel it's our duty and
obligation to share these stories with
people and so uh we've had a couple of
filming opportunities that have come our
way not not ones that we've actually
sought for which is the way we want it
like we know we want God's timing to be
perfect in this and we really want it
done in a way that that takes all the
credit off of our table you know like we
don't want anybody to look at us and say
wow this is because getting rescue and
they're just you know they're armed to
teeth they look at their cool vest or
look at their you know amazing put the
lens on the right person it has nothing
to do with that if you guys could
literally see how this operation is run
by human standpoints you know people
would laugh um but uh you know what we
found is that you know God is faithful
and um and as we've been faithful to
that message he has then put us in
positions so that we can tell the story
that that gives him all the credit and
all the glory and um we had Daniel hosle
who's with Advent World radio he
actually came with us to Ukraine uh back
in September of this last year and he
had an amazing just you know like
experience with the team filming
documenting uh capturing and it was it
was almost it was so weird it was almost
as if God was directing and I believe he
was like God was directing this this
whole story as it was unfolding because
it really like there was no pre thought
or work that we had put into it we
weren't writing scripts or writing like
well we need to capture this piece and
that keep it literally just as it
unfolded God just got Daniel some
amazing footage and amazing Stories and
it just like WAOW I mean this is going
to be incredible so Daniel's working on
that right now the release date is
supposed to be early this year um at
some point he's going to screen it and
let it and let it uh be released and
it's and it's also not just something
that's going to be in the Christian
realm he really actually wants to
release it in the secular world too
because that's where people are really
struggling for hope is they they don't
they don't see the value of what God has
to offer and so Daniel really wants to
be able to reach even that that secular
audience so he's going to try to see if
he can enter it into some film festivals
and whatever so we'll see how God takes
that um and then the next one in Israel
yeah we did have a a guy that joined us
um his name is itamar and uh amazing guy
40-year veteran you know photography
film and uh he's secular he's not a he's
not a Christian he's not a real
religious guy to begin with with and so
it was a really interesting pair up we
didn't seek him out either this was kind
of a a friend of a friend that was like
this is so amazing like can I make some
contacts and we said well if God puts it
together sure who are we to say no um
and so uh he came with us and what was
so amazing about that is that uh he
really was able to see the hand of God
like never before I remember we were at
a loss of where to go next and here we
are in the middle of the Battle Zone you
know things are happening we can't sit
there very long cuz you know we're
sitting ducks and and it's it's kind of
a nerve-wracking situation and so Dylan
and I were talking back for like what do
we do okay where do we go and like and
and in that moment itar in the back seat
with the camera he says he says uh well
you guys should do what you normally do
which you should pray and ask him and uh
it seems like he keeps opening doors and
guiding your footsteps where you need to
be so pray about it and it was like well
yeah of course like good good suggestion
you know we're g to go with that plan it
made uh yeah it made it made it made a
big impact on him and he saw I think he
saw really the heart of what the gospel
is at its core in willing to risk
oneself to give somebody a message of
Hope and he was able to document that
whole thing um and so we're hoping to be
able to put some of those those clips
and that story together in a meaningful
way that's going to tell that story you
know of the journey in Israel um but
it's not just Israel the story is
incomplete um because um you know it's
one thing to go to Ukraine where you're
like well yeah sure you know ukrainians
love Americans and go to Israel yeah
sure you know Israelis love Americans
it's a whole another thing to consider
Fields like uh Gaza you know inside Gaza
you know or or to consider Fields like
Russia you know like how do we get to
Russia but but but that's the thing is
that the gospel is no less um you know
important for these places as well
because God loves the Russians as much
as he loves the ukrainians and I
guarantee you from what I I'm just going
to put this out here as a disclaimer
from what we've seen on the ground is
not what they're feeding you in the news
news you are not getting the full
picture there is a lot of manipulation
that's happening here and and it's
because there are political agendas that
are huge that are moving this world into
the very place where prophecy said we
would be and that is where no man may
buy or sell save he received the mark of
that system and unless you go with that
system you will be cut out of that
system in a significant way in order to
try to bring you to your knees to
capitulate but that but but God has a
promise God has God has you know a
thousand ways to provide which we know
nothing of he can hide you beside the
brook cherith like he did for Elijah you
know uh
he's table yeah he can feed you I mean
like this is and and on that note I have
I have to I have to tell you this story
because this is so incredible to give
our you know viewers you know some hope
and encouragement because we live we
live in a scary day and age you know
like with the technology that's
happening around us right now and you
know they're listening to every phone
call they're they're recording all of
your information you know Facebook is
one of the greatest data collector on on
people Hitler would just be so excited
if he had Facebook available from the
1940s and um and yet and yet you know
what God's word is bigger yeah God's
word is stronger am and and I remember
we we we were in um Israel and uh we
came up to a check very heavily
fortified checkpoint and uh and they
said where do you want to go we still
we're trying to go to the South to um
Kadesh Baria which is like a little
kabut in the south about right on the
Egypt border and we were kind of
thinking if we could get to the Egypt
border with Israel maybe we could cross
over into Egypt and then from Egypt we'd
go into Gaza because the Gaza border is
shared with with Egypt so we were just
trying different options Lord how how do
we you know Reach people on all sides of
this and so um they said well okay and
they said what are you what is your
mission what are you doing here show
them showed them the god pods pulled out
our little devices and said we're here
because God's given us a special mission
to give you one of these things and um
and they said yeah sure go through
that's awesome so they opened the gate
they let us through and pretty soon we
found out we're on this road and it was
between Egypt and between Israel and it
was 30 kilomet which is quite a distance
like driving um 30 km on this road and
we were the only ones on this border
road like this high security border road
we're passing these huge tall towers
that have like highres cameras and like
you know like that's how they watch the
borders with all these cameras and and
the Border fence is like you know 60 ft
High you know razor wire giant you know
giant wall like nobody's coming across
that and uh and as we're driving you
know itamar he sees this whole Convoy of
trucks on the other side our cameraman
he's like stop the car stop the car and
he's like all right back the car up so
he backed the car up he's like all right
turn to the left all right so we turn to
the left get a better angle turn to the
right turn to the right get a better
angle and pretty soon you know dyl and I
were a little nervous like man you know
e we got to keep going like we're on
this like board they they're watching us
with these cameras you know like if we
stay here and look like we're monkeying
around on the wall like you know they
may just like decide to take us out um
so so uh so we kept going and when we
got to Kadesh Baria the the guards there
at that side they were so surprised they
were
like they didn't even they weren't even
guarding our road because nobody comes
down that road and so we had to like
knock on the gate and the guard shack be
like hey can we get the gate open you
know so we go through and um they had to
call their superiors it was a big deal
like apparently weren't supposed to be
on that road this this whole whole whole
ordeal they finally let us go and we
went into Kadesh Baria and esar had a
friend there who was like head of
security of that particular little
settlement of that kabut and um his
friend he asked us he said where did you
guys come from and we said we came from
the north he's like what route did you
take and cuz all the routes are are
blocked and like it's a mess like
traveling is is you know long you got to
take a lot of long routes everywhere and
uh we said we came down this one
particular border road and he just
looked at us and he said no you didn't
and we said yeah we did and he said no
you didn't he's like I'm an Israeli he's
like and I'm head of security he's like
they won't even let me on that road he's
there's no way you came down the road I
said well wow I don't know what to tell
you but itamar has footage of it you
know like we we were on this road you
know and so he was he was blown away but
it just gave greater weight when we told
him why we were here when we gave him
the the godp Pod when he gave him the
message of why we were here he was just
he was in he was amazed and he said well
I want you he said I want you to meet
this unit of of all female soldiers that
are up on the hill and their
responsibility is border security like I
need you you guys have an amazing story
and what you're doing I I want you to
meet so we did we went up to the hill
met these female Fighters and um it it's
the only female unit in all of Israel
727 is their unit and um and so we just
interacted with these girls they were
very curious as to who we were and what
we were doing we told them what we're
there for and had just an amazing it was
it was that first night was the first
night of Hanukkah so we end up lighting
like the first candle of Hanukkah we we
taught him the song This Little Light of
Mine because uh they they they you know
that's what you do when you do Hanukkah
you sing songs and so they were like
that's a good song for them and we were
like ah This Little Light of Mine you
know it was like it was perfect and and
they were like what song is that I was
like well it's a song we teach our kids
you know and it's amazing you know um
beautiful and we didn't hold back like
we told these we told these girls we
told these girls where this world's
headed we told them exct exactly what's
about to happen you know and that's the
P that's the power of the gift of
Prophecy God has given us the gift of
Prophecy to understand what's going to
happen next and with Assurance you can
know what are the next major events
maybe not all the details in between but
you can know what's about to happen and
and this this is the power of God's word
and so as we deliver that to them they
were just in awe I mean as Israeli girls
most of them very secular one of them
she was she was full-on in a in a um you
know an lgbqt lifestyle and she had
questions for us and so and it just the
whole thing opened up in just this
incredible evening where we shared with
them and right as we're about to depart
Dylan you know he he looks they have
this you know video screen where they're
watching the the border with these
highres cameras and the whole time we
were there they had this huge drone I
mean huge drone I think it was probably
like 7 feet in diameter the thing was
ginormous and and the thing was
constantly up in the air the only time
they brought it down was to change the
battery pack out then it was back up up
in the air and they were just patrolling
the whole time we were there we were
talking to a couple but but most of them
had their eyes fixed and their attention
fixed on watching the board they're
zooming on a little lady on the other
side that's picking up sticks and uh and
so Dylan he just asked me he said hey he
said we came down this road you know a
couple hours ago on our little Avis
Rental Car you know like what uh what
did you guys see and they were like no
you didn't you didn't come down that
road like we did and they're like no you
didn't they said we've been watching
this border the whole time if you would
have come down the road we would have
seen you we' have known we would been
tracking you they said nobody's even
allowed on this road they said the Army
is not even allowed on this road unless
they have special permission and air
support and like an escort and all these
things there's no way that you came down
this road in a rental car and you just
drove down this border road and we
didn't see you because we've been
watching this and we believed and we're
like look you guys are diligent in your
job we're not trying to say that you're
you're you're slacking or you're
sleeping on the job right I know you
guys are diligent what you're doing you
guys are the best right it's how you've
been trained but at the same time we
told them listen this is the power of
God that's when pull out the godp Pod
and you show them the invisible button
on the front and you say you know look
this is has a incognito mode right here
that if you actually turn it on and
listen to it people will not see
you yeah and and so that's that's the
but that's the point is that can God
hide us when he needs to and the answer
is yes even the most powerful Security
State in the Western World Israel has
has security like you would not believe
man SC scary stuff on how they're
tracking and watching people and and yet
Psalms 91 says that if we take shelter
under the shadow of the almighty if we
hide under his wings we will be covered
that's right yeah abiding in the
shadow man who wouldn't want that
promise in this scary day in day and age
in which we live who does not want that
kind of protection for their family for
their friends for their loved ones for
themselves like like Lord hide me in
your Pavilion you know if if I need to
be hidden cover me when I need to be
covered be my shield be my buckler be my
Tower of defense like this is the power
of God's word and it's living it's quick
like you don't you don't need a gun in
your hands you need the word of God in
your hands in your heart in your mind
like this is this is the need for today
that's right ah Brock those are
beautiful stories and I am looking
forward to seeing this documentary that
you guys are working on um I can't wait
for this thing to be out but you guys
know it takes resources to make the kind
of things so if you want to help support
Brock's Mission which is literally
putting the Bible in the hands of people
on the front lines please look his
ministry up check him out and then pay
attention to uh Gideon Gideon rescue
when uh they release the documentary um
um you will want to see some of these
stories because they are truly amazing
um Brock as you uh uh sign off here
though set up the uh the video you you
want to show with uh a woman that came
and started working with your ministry
and she really caught the vision of your
ministry um tell us a little bit about
her yeah um you know sometimes you don't
realize the impact that you have on
people um and uh we were doing a swift
water Rescue Training Up in Oklahoma
City and sometimes even our trainings
we're kind of wondering like Lord like
is this really maybe we just need to be
training people how to hand out a piece
of literature A Bible you know cuz
that's really like the greatest need so
what is what is Swift water really going
to gain us here in the end but you know
in that training we had this mom who
came and she was so excited about it she
was just like on fire for her her little
kid he was 8 years old and banner um and
we had some we had some real amazing
times with this this kid was like he was
he was that kid that you'd throw him in
the water and he wouldn't get out like
he he just wanted to do it again and
again and again until he was at the
point of like total exhaustion we had to
pluck him out of the water and sit him
on the bank and say hey man you need you
need a breather like you know you're not
going to you're not going to make it
next round around if you don't take a
break you know he was so into it so
excited about the skills that he was
learning um you know his life jacket was
two sizes too big and his helmet was
falling over his face you know but he
just he was having the blast of his life
and his mom had driven there like three
plus hours to come and train with us and
she did it like two or three times that
we did trainings in the summer this
couple it was a year ago I think it was
about a year ago and uh we didn't see
her or hear from her for about a year
and we kind of wondered like hey you
know what happen you know some and
sometimes it happens like we get people
that are interested in what we do and
they kind of come in and come out and we
don't see them for a
while and um she came back that next
summer and she said can I just tell you
guys like what God's been doing in my
life and we're like well yeah of course
and she had this incredible testimony
this incredible story of of just like
tragedy like that's what had kept her
from us knowing what was going on in her
life and uh she was going through this
incredible struggle and we had no idea
and she didn't even reach out to us not
even not even a request for prayer so um
but but she just told us in the
aftermath of this she was like that that
time that I had with you guys gave me
courage and gave me the setup that I
needed to face that tragedy because of
the mindset that you guys were talking
about when you go into these disasters
when you go into these places and your
number one focus is giving people hope
and it was just like whoa and so that
that's that's the story really I mean I
don't want to ruin it for people that
listen to it but it's just it was so
inspiring to see somebody who who just
really captured that and encapsulated
that in a very personal situation in
life that made all the difference in the
world and and if that's all we can do is
just inspire people with that then game
over I mean that's we're we're satisfied
like amen let's do it amen all right
we're going to play that video right now
you will be blessed by watching this
video I guarantee
it I was able to join Gideon rescue my
son and I were able to join Gideon
rescue for a Whitewater training event
in Oklahoma City a couple of times
several times and uh the first worship
that they had um before the event began
um they spoke about that their worship
was about being bold for God and so when
I heard that worship it just made me cry
because um I just felt confirmation that
this was where God was leading me to um
develop boldness for him and that being
in the company of Gideon rescue was the
right place for me to be so um my son
and I spent a couple of um weekends
doing the Swiftwater
training and while it gave us skills um
to help in a flood situation or
something like that it ALS also just
gave me time to talk with um Brock and
Greg and Corey and Wy and it gave me
time to absorb their
philosophy um towards uh sharing the
gospel you can tell that these
[Music]
people believe
that the Lord is coming so soon there is
no excuse to not
share
and if a man is drowning you're going to
do everything to go and and save that
man and they approach um sharing the
word of God with people that don't know
Jesus these are drowning people and and
we need to do everything we can make
ourselves look like fools if necessary
um to get that word in front of them to
to give them the name of Jesus and
so the philosophy of Gideon rescue
company is such
that the Lord opens doors in the worst
of
situations and even though people think
that this is all about me losing my
house and me losing my car and me losing
you know our town is destroyed or
whatever and then Gideon rescue comes in
and provides
whatever care they
can that's not what it's all about what
it's all about is the prayer that these
people have with those who have lost
everything it's about um the literature
that they're able to share with
them and it's about taking that golden
opportunity to put the name of Jesus
before people who are now in a situation
where they will accept it like never
before and that meant everything to me
that changed the way that I looked at
life and so I started looking at life
as what what opportunity lies before me
and how can I boldly go forward and
share god with
somebody when
the
[Music]
radiologist looked at the scans and he
said this is suspicious for
cancer I was
shocked um to say the least and I didn't
really know what to
think but I left the clinic that day
walked out to my car I was by myself
because I wasn't expecting to get bad
news that day and um I had my Bible in
the car and so I just sat in my car in
the parking lot and I opened up my Bible
and I read a few verses I turned on my
um music I listened to a couple of um
songs and then I just
prayed that God
would do with this cancer what he wants
to do um it was the most surreal and
strange feeling of peace
that I've exper experienced but I was
thinking about job and how he had just
lost everything and he had just lost his
children and his First Act was to
worship God and I wanted that to go down
on my record in heaven I just got the
worst news that I've ever gotten but I
wanted worship to be my first act and so
I gave the cancer to God and I asked him
to do something with it because um I
have a family I have four children and I
did not know how my story was going to
end
[Music]
so I took the philosophy of Gideon
rescue into my cancer
clinic and
um whenever I would go I would bring
literature with me and I would put it in
a little baggie with chocolates and
whenever I would see somebody that would
look a little sad um I would pray about
who to give this literature
to and I had surgery to remove uh the
tumor
and I was on the surgery table just
about to go under and I I told um the
surgeon and the people there um thank
you for for how you're about to save my
life and um I want to pray with you and
so I was able to pray with them and then
after my surgery I gave my surgeon a
gift which to me is the greatest gift
that I can possibly give which is a copy
of the book Desire of Ages um it talks
all about the life of Jesus and it has
changed my life and brought me closer um
to the Lord and I wanted to share that
with
her so um a few weeks later my surgeon
called me and she said thank you so much
for giving me that book it's on my night
table right now and I've already started
reading it and so I was just so grateful
and I thought Lord if
you saw fit that I should have cancer so
that I could give this book this
beautiful book that talks about you to
this person and that's the only
reason that's okay with me and I'm just
really grateful that you would use me to
do
that
um I got
chickenpox uh I I went through chemo and
my white blood cells were very low and
um my son was exposed to chickenpox at
school and so I got it from him and it
was very very bad I had to go to the
hospital for 8 days because they thought
that it might go into my brain and be a
bad
situation um and while I was there in
the hospital uh I was able to pray with
a nurse there and I told her you know if
I got chickenpox and I had to come to
this Hospital just to get to know you
and have this prayer um and talk to you
about your boyfriend that is not
treating you right um and encouraging
you to talk to Jesus about it then
that's okay with me and um I consider
that a huge privilege and just last
month I finished my uh 20 weeks of chemo
and I gave my nurses I had four nurses I
gave them all a copy of the book steps
to Christ and so over each and every one
of those pieces of literature I would
pray that the Holy Spirit would go with
that book go with that pamphlet and
would
call that person to to be attracted to
it to read it to open it up and I also
wrote inside of it telling them thank
you for being such a great nurse and
hope that they don't throw it away
simply because it was written and um um
because the message of life is in that
book The Desire of Ages is an incredible
book and it leads people to the Bible
which is everything
so I I stand here today incredibly
grateful to have gotten to known a group
of people that take so seriously that we
are living in the very last days and
that every stop needs to be pulled in
order to get people to know who Jesus is
and it has helped me through my own
personal
crisis it has helped me approach it
with
gratefulness
and
humility
just um such gratitude to God that he
would honestly this is honestly how I
feel and I know it sounds weird but I'm
just grateful that he would trust me
with
this and let me be able to talk to other
cancer patients a group of people I
never thought I would have access
to
and I don't know how I would have
approached it if I hadn't met getting
and rescue um they're very very special
to me and to my
son and um I'm cancer free today I want
to leave you with that um God has
answered our prayers
and the surgery has removed the cancer I
still have some more treatment to go
through but my doctor says that I'm
cancer free and so this is very good
news for me and for my family and
honestly however it ends whatever
happens I am fully fully committed to
using everything that happens to me and
in my life for the Lord's honor and
glory and um I give him praise and I
thank my brothers and sisters at Gideon
rescue that is such a powerful Story I
mean literally this summarizes the
entire gospel message into this very
concise even in the face of tragedy
you're wanting to bless someone else
you're thinking of somebody else I mean
Stacy's story was so inspiring to me I
remember when you shared this video with
me I just sat in my driveway and just
tears were streaming down my face and I
was just thinking like if I was going to
die if I thought I was going to die Lord
let me go out like this like let me let
me let me lit literally come onto the
surgery table and say can I pray with
you is there something I can pray with
you about like like what a beautiful
story and I'm so glad that that you
shared this video with me it gave me a
lot of inspiration and a lot of Hope and
um yeah what an impactful story yeah
it's it really is amazing um and I I
think it really does show like what
happens when when the Full Gospel takes
a hold of someone because that's exactly
what Jesus did for us you know like in
the in the midst of the greatest tragedy
I mean his own cre ation is all against
him nailing him to a
cross and his thoughts on his mind is
not his Agony it's not his it's not his
tragedy he's not thinking about like oh
it's so horrible I'm I'm so victimized
here and so shamed and nobody cares
nobody's standing for my disciples have
all fled and left me his his only
thought on his count it against them
against yeah father forgive them for
they know not what they do or or when
he's thinking about his mother John John
he's in agony and he's thinking of his
mother's Agony this is your mother John
like take care of her right you know
like I mean like this is like it shows
you the heart of God it shows you the
heart of God yeah and and and when the
when the thief turns to him and just
says you know Lord remember me you know
I mean that Jesus is I mean must that's
what must have thrilled his heart
because he was like it's worth it like
all this pain all this suffering all the
tragedy if it's just for one you it's
worth it you bring up a really good
point when people see that you are
literally there for not your own Comfort
not your own kingdom not your own
whatever you think you want in life but
you're there for someone else and
willing to put yourself in danger how
can you not respond to that how can you
not be like this this ve this shows you
the very Heart Of God that's what the
heart of God is I will put myself at
risk to come and save you yeah and
that's and that's why the Centurion
right like this guy who's totally Pagan
right he's been raised in Pagan religion
Pagan philosophy he's never seen the
truth except for on that day in it in
the darkest hour The Darkest Hour the
Centurion looks at Jesus and he says
surely this was the son of God he sees
that kind of love no human being can
have that kind of love pouring out of
them unless they are literally connected
to the Divine I mean that that's that's
what the secular mindset would say that
that is is ludicrous for anyone in this
um dog eat dog and and you know survival
of the fittest world that that the devil
has duped everybody to believe that
that's what living is right I got to get
mine before you got to get yours and
this is flipping that narrative on its
head and Stacy's story is a real
practical example of that and I just I
was hugely impacted by that story and
that was a beautiful beautiful beautiful
well-edited video and so I really Brock
look forward to seeing your documentary
because you guys this guy has flown into
disasters when turkeys bombed out and
and and and like literally leveled to
the ground they're flying in there with
Blackhawk helicopters the government is
dropping them off because God literally
opened those doors and so it's just
seems like story after story after Story
of this I I have to go go on one of
these trips Brock like I'm literally
like ready to go but um I'm really
praying for your ministry Gideon rescue
um I hope that you guys have far and
wide um success in winning many souls to
the kingdom and I'm sure only in heaven
will we actually see what what kind of
work you you your your ministry has been
able to do and uh I think it's
absolutely beautiful I'm very honored to
be connected to this young man right
here Brock is my little brother and uh
I just absolutely love this kid to death
he inspires me like to no end and it's
beautiful to be in Ministry have Brock
be in Ministry uh I got another brother
Tom in Ministry and um man that's what
it's about you guys get involved like
this is literally the end of the world
and if you don't have some active
involvement in a Ministry if you are not
there pray for people in ministries
that's an active ministry right there if
you have Financial means help fund some
of these Ministries get involved get to
know a Ministry uh link up with them
donate to them uh this is part of
ministry and actually that is as much
actively involved in the ministry as
Brock going out there and and handing
those godp pods out those things are
expensive and it's beautiful that uh
Adventist World radio radio that donated
those I mean he they've donated pallets
of these things to them and they're
expensive so I mean there's a lot of
different Ministries that you guys can
get involved in to help finish this work
and get the gospel out before there is
no time and so I hope that you guys were
very blessed by Today's Show um please
look Gideon rescue up if you are young
or old or whatever and you want to get
involved I mean these guys have a wide
range of people that donate time to them
and and go on the rescue missions with
them and so start connecting with him on
Facebook start connecting with him on
YouTube or or you know call him up you
can get his phone number and and uh go
and do some of these awesome trainings
that they have and uh we know that
things in the world are not going to
necessarily get better in fact the Bible
tells us it's going to get much worse so
while we have the ability while we have
the energy now is the time and that's
why we want to share this message with
you so we hope you guys were super
blessed by today um thank you Brock for
being on board and uh coming and sharing
us with what Gideon rescues up to and uh
we will clearly be checking in with you
later down the road as uh things kind of
develop in your ministry but um we we
hope you guys were super blessed and um
please subscribe like share this video
you know um it really helps us push
these these ideas out and you guys are
are able to help us and that's even a
small Ministry just just liking and
sharing the video or subscribing to it
that in itself is helping the content
get out to more people so please if you
haven't done that before smash that that
subscribe button and uh we will
definitely want to keep this ministry in
our prayers and uh keep our ministry in
your prayers as well may God bless you
and we'll see you next time on LED
live if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little like kids
if you're looking for a way to spruce up
your wardrobe this year check out
lightwear do shop it's a christian-owned
apparel company with the belief that we
are all walking Billboards one of the
best ways to share your witness is to
wear your witness these conversation
starter designs are the perfect way to
look good while shining your light for
Christ for a limited time use promo code
love for 15% off your entire order
that's 15% off for new clothing for you
and maybe a gift for someone special so
go to lightwear do shop and remember use
promo code
[Music]
love